bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo nouvel épisode de Loki la
semaine dernière nous étions plus dans
une vidéo orienté théorie cette fois-ci
vu que nous sommes sur un épisode un
petit peu plus posé et qui prépare le
grand final vu qu'il reste qu'un épisode
nous allons essayer de plus nous focus
sur de l'analyse afin de nous-même nous
préparer l'épisode 6 de Loki saison 2
c'est dans moins d'une semaine dans la
première saison le 6e épisode c'était
vraiment le moment révélation qui nous
apportait toutes les réponses et il est
obligé que ce soit la même chose pour
cette saison 2 on ne va pas se mentir
les thématiques sont complexes on baigne
complètement dans les aspects compliqués
du multivers du voyage dans le temps des
boucles des paradoxes et cetera et
cetera néanmoins tout sera quand même
bien plus clair une fois le final digéré
avec au passage l'annonce très
certainement d'une petite saison 3
l'épisode 5 s'ouvre directement après
l'explosion du cœur temporel et très
vite vite nous allons être témoins que
loky time sleep à nouveau bon on ne va
pas se mentir on se doutait clairement
que cela allait être la solution au
problème vu que le concept a été mis de
côté très tôt après l'épisode 1 alors
que pourtant le trailer de la série nous
disait le contraire cependant chose que
je trouve intéressante je le place comme
ça vous en faites ce que vous voulez
mais je trouve que quelque chose a
changé dans le TVA déjà nous semblons
bel et bien post explosion tout
simplement car il y a toujours la
machine où Victor timely a identifié son
AAT temporel sans parler du fait que
nous avons toujours le clignotement des
lumières au sein même du TVA d'ailleurs
il y a aussi le code TVA 1229 le mode de
sécurité du TVA qui s'est activé mode
qui semble avoir renvoyé tous les
membres du TVA dans leur vie d'origine
afin de les protéger mais bref pour
revenir à ce que je disais contrairement
à tout ça le cœur temporel semble tenir
et mieux que ça encore je le trouve
trouve différent en fait j'ai comparé
cette scène à l'épisode 1 et j'ai bien
l'impression de ne pas voir la même
chose après l'explosion le cœur semble
plus gros et de plus il tourne élément
qui correspondait au plan d'obby dans
l'épisode 4 mais autre élément qui
s'ajoute à cette idée c'est que le
moniteur nous dit loom stabilizing le
cœur se stabilise alors que pourtant
obby nous affirmait dans l'épisode 1
face aux nouvelles branches que c'était
un véritable désastre peut-être que je
m'emballe peut-être que le blan est
juste un petit peu différent mais vu que
tout est une boucle on voit la fin puis
le début puis on revient dans le présent
alors est-ce que ce ne serait pas
annonciateur d'un moment de répi entre
guillemets pour le TVA alors oui je dis
répi bah tout simplement car déjà le TVA
disparaît après nous avoir montré ce que
je viens de vous décrire mais surtout il
ne faut pas oublier quand même le
paramètre celui qui demeure ou du moins
c'est variant comme il l'avait annoncé
l'épisode 5 était très sympa on avait
besoin de ce genre d'épisode pour ne pas
précipiter la fin et en même temps
continuer de bien développer l'histoire
et ses personnages c'est marrant de voir
l'origine de nos membres favoris comme
Casey par exemple un prisonnier
d'Alcatraz qui a pour nom Franck tout ça
s'inspire d'une véritable histoire où un
trio de prisonniers se sont évadés de la
célèbre prison sans jamais que leur
corps soit retrouvé sans oublier
évidemment la référence à l'épisode 1 de
la saison 1 de Loki où le dieu de la
malice avait menacé Casey de le vider
comme un poisson ou encore BIFI qui
s'appelle en réalité verity Willis qui
est normalement une protagoniste de
comics ayant partagé des aventures avec
Loki dans la saga lcky agent of Asgard
ou roboros dont l'atelier ressemble
étrangement à son atelier du TVA avec
d'ailleurs une très belle symbolique car
il est normalement un écrivain dont les
livres ne se vendent pas et un
scientifique menoté car il n'a pas de
doctorat et au final dans le TVA il est
l'auteur du manuel du TVA c'est limite
une star on lui demande des autographes
pour son bouquin et il est sans
hésitation d'ailleurs l'employé le plus
remarquable de l'entreprise sans oublier
également notre fameux Mobius où enfin
on le voit avec des jet skis mais
maintenant comment tout ça va se
terminer déjà l'épisode 5 vient nous
prouver à quel point le TVA est
nécessaire pour l'existence et c'est
clairement la faute de celui qui demeure
en fait maintenant on ne peut plus se
passer du flux temporel sacré qui est la
création de celui qui demeure et qui est
du coup géré par le TVA or reboot
complet de tout ce qui existe si l'on
supprime le flux temporel sacré et le
TVA c'est la fin de l'existence en
elle-même et de ces nombreuses autres
réalités qui naissent à partir de ce
flux c'est une nouvelle fois une forme
de boucle le TVA dépend du flux temporel
sacré et le flux temporel sacré dépend
du TVA par conséquent cela nous rappelle
bien que les variantes de Kang sont
inévitables et donc le retour de celui
qui demeure et en parlant de ça
justement il faut que l'épisode final
nous apporte un gros teasing à ce sujet
effectivement Loki maîtrise désormais
l'érance temporelle faisant de lui dans
la symbolique le god of stories
puisqu'il est capable de réécrire
l'histoire c'est une petite référence au
comics toujours dans la saga agent of
Asgard oou Loki juste avant
l'effondrement du multivver à cause des
incursions va renaître en tant que Dieu
des histoire avec un pouvoir un peu
similaire à la série comme nous l'avons
vu ce dernier avant la fin de l'épisode
a time slepé au moment de l'épisode 4
juste après que Victor timely a descendu
les escaliers si je ne dis pas de
bêtises c'est le moment clé de la saison
2 toute façon l'explosion du cœur sonne
comme un game over et il faut
recommencer jusqu'à que cela marche et
les derniers plan du trailer semble nous
prouver cette option puisque nous voyons
ALOKI répéter plusieurs fois g et on se
doute qu'il va devoir recommencer
l'histoire jusqu'à trouver la bonne
combinaison puisque nous l'avons vu
revoir le plan avec oboros on le voit
guider ce qui semble être Victor timely
mais où cette fois-ci la radiation ne
l'ont pas tué on voit même Loki aller de
lui-même vers le cœur temporel sans
protection mais surtout nous le voyons
même retourner jusqu'au moment de
l'épisode 1 saison 1 où il était
prisonnier ainsi qu'il semblerait
l'épisode 6 notamment face à celui qui
demeure prête à se faire tuer par Sylvie
en fait nous sommes dans une série où le
personnage principal est Loki le dieu de
la malice a pas mal morflé ces dernières
années la saison 1 de sa série lui a
donné une rédemption malgré que tout est
été dicté par celui qui demeure et là
avec la saison 2 il va falloir lui
donner son fameux gloriousious purpose
son destin glorieux le personnage s'est
trompé et retrompé pendant la saison de
résultant l'explosion du cœur la mort de
ses amis des incertitudes la solitude et
cetera maintenant avec ce pouvoir cheaté
du Time sleeping bah il faut quand même
faire gagner un minimum Loki lui donner
une certaine forme de victoire et
d'ailleurs petit détail je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez de la vidéo qu'on
avait fait pour l'épisode 1 l'analyse
mais je vous avais partagé un haster eg
que j'avais trouvé nous montrant le logo
du TVA mais recouvert de feuilles ce qui
changeait du coup le Time variance
authority en time author l'auteur du
temps je crois bien qu'au final ce petit
détail était bien annonciateur de
quelque chose de plus grand Loki est
désormais l'auteur du temps grâce à son
nouveau pouvoir l'auteur de l'Histoire
qu'il peut réécrire mais bref néanmoins
de l'autre côté la victoire annonce
aussi l'inévitable déjà les rances
temporelles on ne sait toujours pas
réellement comment c'est apparu obi nous
parle de la surcharge du cœur temporel
et donc des surtensions et ce serait ça
qui serait sûrement la cause mais c'est
quand même même bien flou et assez vague
tout ce que nous sommes en train de
vivre a été prévu par celui qui demeure
celui qui demeure que l'on nous rabâche
dans les oreilles depuis l'épisode 1
sans jamais l'avoir vu donc il est temps
bien que le pouvoir de Loki soit
incroyable il est en réalité men noté
puisque peu importe comment il réécrit
l'histoire seul deux résultats sont
possibles soit le TVA est détruit et on
l'a déjà vécu et donc il n'y a plus des
existence soit Loki réussit à empêcher
la fusion et par conséquent le flux et
les branches continuent de vivre mais du
coup cela veut donc dire la renaissance
des variants de celui qui demeure qui
déclencheront la guerre multiverselle
sans le savoir Loki va être celui qui va
provoquer la guerre multiverselle mais
il n'a pas réellement le choix par
conséquent à la fin de la saison 2 nous
devons avoir un teasing à ce sujet Loki
saison 1 nous propose la fin du récit
avec celui qui demeure à la fin des
temps régnant surt la saison 2 nous
montre l'origine le début de la
formation de ce qui se passera à
l'avenir même dans la symbolique la
série Loki elle-même avec ses deux
saisons nous propose une boucle dans
tous les cas je pense très certainement
que nous aurons une saison 3 comme je
vous l'ai toujours dit la série Loki
nous accompagne tout le long de la saga
du multivers pour nous éduquer nous
expliquer et nous montrer ce qu'il y a
derrière le rideau et vu qu'il y a trois
phases dans une saga Marvel une saison 3
pour la phase 6 bon c'est pas déconnant
de l'affirmer d'ailleurs on n'oublie pas
ravona qui nous sera forcément montré
dans le dernier épisode je vous avais
déjà partagé mes impressions la
concernant dans la dernière vidéo mais
le fait de ne pas nous l'avoir montré
dans l'épisode 5 me conforte encore plus
dans l'idée de ce que je vous avais dit
si on garde ce qui entoure ravona et le
néant pour le dernier épisode c'est bien
pour nous montrer quelque chose de
choquant une grosse révélation la
concernant je vous le répète mais il y a
un lien lien entre elle et alios si
c'est vraiment ravona qui a changé le
cours de la guerre nous savons qu'alios
est l'instrument qui a permis de la
gagner et au vu de l'inspiration de base
des comics voilà je pense que vous avez
compris n'hésitez pas à revoir la vidéo
dédiée à l'épisode 5 et pour le moment
je pense que nous allons nous arrêter là
à vous de me dire en commentaire vos
impressions et ce que vous avez pensé de
l'épisode je vous avoue que désormais
j'ai quand même très hâte de voir la fin
nous nageons dans le mystère depuis 5
semaines il nous faut désormais le
dénouement celui qui demeure nous disait
que loky et Sylvie étaient
indubitablement ses successeurs avant
son retour et je trouve ça intéressant
qu'au final sylvie a été l'agent du
chaos en relançant le libre arbitre et
en tuant celui qui demeure en plus quand
on regarde la saison 1 c'est limite si
ce n'est pas plutôt Sylvie le personnage
principal de l'histoire et là à
contrario nous sommes totalement centrés
sur l'autre élu de celui qui demeure
Loki qui lui va ramener l'ordre issu du
chaos et donc préparer sans le savoir le
retour du prime Kang celui qui demeure
bref j'espère que ma vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser un
petit pouce bleu et à vous abonner le
mois de novembre risque d'être chargé on
se retrouve dès la semaine prochaine
pour le grand final de loky mais
également pour le film the marvels qui
devrait amener des éléments très
intéressants pour le MCU s'il ramène
vraiment le concept d'incursion donc
nous allons avoir du taf sur ce que le
lion heart soit avec vous c'était
argoroc allez ciao tout le
[Musique]
monde